翻訳: Hiroko Kawano
校正: Takahiro Shimpo
みなさん こんにちは
私は映像クリエーター そして
イラストレーターの重光 あさみです
本日はよろしくお願いします
私は人の心を動かすものに興味があります
突然ですが みなさん
どのように生きていますか？
好きなものはありますか？
ワクワクどきどきする時は
一体どんな時ですか？
私の大好きなことと言えば
絵を描くこと
映像を見ることも大好きで
映画を見ることも もちろん大好きだし
そして 映画・映像のアイデアを
考えることも大好き
そして 人と話すことが大好きです
そんな私は人と話すことが好きでもあり
独りの時間もとても大切にしています
そんな私が行っているプロジェクトについて
ひとつお話したいと思います
はい 私はこのようなことを行っています
みなさん 一体これが
何だか分かりますか？
ここの中央部にあるもの
これ 一体なんだと思いますか？
これはショートケーキなんです
一体ここで何をやっているか？
もう少し近づいてみましょう
はい ケーキの横に
人がちょっとわらわらといますね
はい 何をやっているのか？
正解はピクニックです
はい なぜ一体ショートケーキの横で
ピクニックをやっているのか？
ちょっとね みなさんも
なんでだろうと思うと思うんですけど
これはただ 友達と友達を呼んできて
一緒にピクニックを
やろうっていう形でやって
主催しているものではありません
初めて会った人と
老若男女 男女性別年齢も問わず
誰もが 初めての人でも
参加していいピクニックを
毎月22日に主催しています
このような形で
ピクニックをしていると言うと
何をやっているの？って
思われると思うんですが
本当に食べ物を持ち寄ったり
もちろん食べ物を
持っていない方も遊びにきて
一緒にゴザの上で
たわいもない話をしています
みなさん このような ショートケーキが
突然 街に現れたらどう思うでしょうか？
（小声で）「ちょっと何だろうあれ？」
多分 ショートケーキだよね 」
そのようにきっと
思われるんじゃないでしょうか？
でも一体何をやっているか分からない
すっごく気になる
ちょっとワクワクどきどきしませんか？
そうやって そんな
ワクワクどきどきした気持ちを持って
みなさんは聞きに来てくれます
「一体これは なんなんですか？」
「ショートケーキです」
「あ ショートケーキなのは
多分 分かるんですけど」
という形で聞いてきてくれます
そこで一体何をしているのか？
「はい それはピクニックをやっているんですよ」
「え？ピクニックですか？」
「はい そうなんです
一緒にピクニックしませんか？」
「一緒にですか？」
「はい 一緒にピクニックしましょう」
そうやっていろんな人を巻き込みながら
私たちはピクニックをしています
こうやっていろんな（笑）
この写真ちょっと面白いですよね
こうやってこのショートケーキが
あることによって
いろんな話題がそこから生まれます
「どうしてショートケーキなの？」
「どうして22日なの？」
「どうしてここでやってるの？」
「どうしてなの？」
という みなさん そういう好奇心を
持って質問にきてくれるんですね
私はこの場がもちろん
「ショートケーキはなんなんですか？」
って聞くことにも
もちろん ハードルはあると思うんですが
コミュニケーションを取ろうとしてないうちに
自然とみんなが
コミュニケーションを取って
何か新しいものが生まれている
そしてその新しい発見や会話を
みんなでシェアしている
そういう 私はこの場が大好きです
本当に何が起こるかわからなくて
本当に突然この人たちは
沖縄民謡を歌ってる人たちなんですが
急に「歌ってもいいですか？」
という形で
遊びにきて下さいました
これも 突然の出会いで
みんながハイジャンプを
することになった写真なんですけど
こうやって 何が起こるかわからない
という空間を
私はすごく大事にしていまして
しかもそれをシェアするということを
私はすごく大事に思っています
もしこの場でもちろん出会った人たちは
このようにハイジャンプをしたり
歌を歌ったり
こうやって
美味しそうに食べようとしたり
いろんな面白いことが もちろん
起こるかもしれないのですが
ここだけではなくて
フェイスブックやツイッター
今 色んなものがありますよね？
そういうところで
もしかして 自分が知らないどこかで
そのお話を誰かがしているかもしれない
そんなことに対しても
私はすごく嬉しく思っているんです
このお母さんはもしかしたら家で
「あなた 今日は
こんなケーキを見たのよ！」
「おお どんなケーキだい？」
そんな話をしながらきっとまさか
こんな大きいケーキだとは
思わないですよね
そんなことを言いながらこうやって
この場所をやっているのですが
大変なことも勿論ありましたが
私はこの場所をもう２年半
毎月22日にやっているので
そうですね 30回
30ヶ月もこの活動を行っています
そして勿論この活動もこれからも続けて
いきたいという風に思っています
私が大学を卒業する前に
大学の先生から
「大学を卒業する前に
３つのモットーを挙げなさい」
という風に言われました
そのモットーは「ものづくりをする上で
表現する上で大切にしていく
３つのモットーを挙げなさい」
半分 課題のようなものですね
「それをちゃんと言ったら卒業させてあげます」
というふうなものですね
そこで私が挙げたものはこの３つです
「ワクワクすること」
「どきどきすること」
「そしてそれを共有すること」
この３つを挙げました
私はワクワクすること
どきどきすること
自分の心に素直になること
そこから人の全ては始まっている
そういう風に思っています
私は勿論このピクニックも
元々ミュージックビデオの
セットで使ったものです
ですが このケーキが要らなくなった
でもこのケーキ一生懸命に
みんなで作ったからもったいないよね
じゃあ何かこのケーキを使って
みんなで面白いことが何かできないか？
そういう風にしてまず私がその話を
みんなにシェアして
そこから「じゃあ一緒にやりたい」
っていう形で
このプロジェクトが始まりました
もちろん 私はこのことを
仕事でも大切にしています
アーティストさんの
ミュージックビデオを作る際に
音楽を聴きます
その音楽 そこをまず自分が一番に
感じるんですね
アーティストさんのここがすごく良い
ここがすごく好きだな
ここがすごく素敵だな
そういうところを感じとって
それを一体どんな風に
伝えていけばいいのか？
どんな風にどんな風な絵で
どんな風な映像で
どんな風な衣装で
伝えていけばいいのか？
シェアしていけばいいのか？
そういう風に考えているのが
私のお仕事です
みなさん みなさんにとって
ワクワクどきどきする時は
一体どんな時でしょうか？
私は今ものづくりをする上での
３つのモットーというお話をしました
でもこれはものづくりのモットー
だけではないと私は思っているんです
自分らしく生きていくための
みなさんに大切にして欲しい
３つの考えでもあると
私は思ってるんです
私が最初 人とお話しするのが
好きという話をしました
でも 独りで引きこもって
独りの時間を過ごすのも大好きです
それはなぜかと言いますと
自分の耳に 自分の心の中の声に
耳を傾けることができるからです
それはすごく小さな声かもしれません
すごく些細なことかもしれません
例えばお風呂に入って
ぼおっとしているとき
明日これがしたいな
ちょっとやってみようかな？
やってみようかな
っていう風に思わなくても
その小さな声は
本当に小さな声はころがっていると
私は思っています
「なんだか今日は黒い服じゃなくて
ちょっと明るい服がいいような気がする」
「今日はすごい雨が降っているなあ」
「でもなんだろう？耳をすませたら
この雨の音ってすごく心地いい気がする」
「今日はお天気が良かったけど
夕日はすごく綺麗なのかな？」
そんな風に部屋の中にいるときでも
少しでも感じたことはないでしょうか？
今少しだけ考えてみてください
みなさんの中でワクワクすること
どきどきすること
それは一体どんな時ですか？
今少しだけ想像してみてください
少し 思いつきましたか？
何か感じたことはありましたか？
私は先ほど このモットーは
ものづくりのことだけではないという風に
お話をしました
私はワクワクどきどきすること
そしてその気持ちに耳を傾けること
それに素直になること
それはとってもクリエイティブな
時間だと思うんです
決して絵が描けなくても
決して歌が歌えなくても
決して踊りが踊れなくても
ものがつくれなかったとしても
みなさんは表現者であり
アーティストである
私はそういう風に思っています
ワクワクすること
どきどきすること
それに少し耳を傾けてみたら
次は共有してみませんか？
私は大学を卒業するときに
さっきの３つのモットーなんですが
この３つのモットーのうち
２つはすぐに出てきました
ワクワクすること
どきどきすること
そうやって私が絵を描いて
そうやってものを作ってきたからなんです
でも３つ目はすぐに出てきませんでした
そこで３つのモットー私
一体なんなんだろう？と考えていました
そのときに１本の映像を見ました
それはテレビのCMで
まったくその商品は出てこないんですが
とても美しいCMでした
まるで神戸のような
すごい急な坂道のある町です そこは
日本ではなく海外の
レンガの建物が並ぶ美しい町です
そこの坂のてっぺんから
ものすごい数のたくさんのカラフルな
スーパーボールを上から放つんです
それがものすごくきれいで
ちょっと言葉で表現するのは
すごく難しいんですが
私はその映像を見たときに
その美しさに本当に感動しました
そしてその時に思ったんです
ああ これは誰かの
ワクワクどきどきする気持ちが
こういう形で 私の元に届いたんだ
そういう風に感じました
もしかしたらその誰かが
ワクワクどきどきを持って
誰かにそれを伝えて一緒に作ろうって
言ったのかもしれません
それを届けてくれた人に
とても私は感謝しました
そして思ったんです
「あ 共有してもらったんだ
これが共有するってことなんだな」
そういう風に感じました
だから私は３つ目のモットーを
自分もワクワクどきどきしたことを
人に共有したい届けたい
そういう風に思って
３つ目のモットーを
「共有する」に決めました
「共有すること」
それが一体なんなんだろう？
そう思うかもしれません
それはとても単純なことで
誰かに今日あったことを話してみる
自分の大好きなものを話してみる
「私 パンが大好きなの」
そんな話をしてみる
「え？ご飯派だと思ってたけど
パンだったの？」
本当にそんなことでもいい
「今日すごい大きなケーキ見たんだよ」
ちょっとその話をしてみる
自分がちょっとでもワクワクどきどき
「美しいな」「感動したな」
と思ったものがあれば
シェアしてほしい
共有してほしい
そんな風に思います
それが誰かの元に届いたときに
もしかしたらその誰かは
あなたを応援してくれるかもしれません
そしてその届いたワクワクどきどきが
新しい価値になって
あなたにも見えるかもしれません
自分が好きだったものが
こんな見え方があるんだ
こんな風に考える人もいるんだ
そうやって自分の好きなものが
より深まっていくかもしれません
だから みなさんに
是非ワクワクどきどきする気持ちを
惜しみなく誰かに発信してほしいなあ
そういう風に私は思います
そしてその発信して共有したことは
必ず自分に返ってきます
ワクワクどきどきする気持ちをすると
自分に必ず返ってくるんです
そして その気持ちを選び続けること
そうすると
大好きなものと大好きな人たちと
それをずっとワクワクドキドキしながら
ワクワクどきどきしながら
みんなが自分らしく生きていけると
私はそういう風に思うんです
ワクワクすること
どきどきすること
そしてそれを共有すること
これがみなさんにとって
自分らしく生きていける
ヒントになりますように
今日のこのTEDxの出来事が
みなさんの心に少しでも響いて
またどんな形か 誰かの元に届いたら
最高に嬉しいなと私は思います
本日はありがとうございました
（拍手）